this slab of stone will soon become a
work of art it's going to be part of the
facade of Berlin's new city palace each
below of the mallet needs to be
perfectly placed first I make guidance
lines at a right angle then a surface
ends up as a straight line in the end
these are the pedestals for the palace
entrance the stone masonry company in
Saxony employs 20 Masons and stone
carvers they'll provide hundreds of
stone blocks for the palace
that's a man can you give me a grinder
Sven Schubert shows his apprentice how
it's done let's talking for probably the
last skilled craft where you can see
your own final product in the end each
block of sandstone has its assigned
position in the facade there's a
schematic drawing hanging on the wall of
the workshop it shows what each finished
block will look like and where it will
be fixed and this is the actual
construction site where berlin city
palace is taking shape a carved block
made by schubert stonemasons is being
hoisted into place it weighs nearly a
ton and costs about 2,000 euros about 15
metres of blocks are fixed in place each
day
what is there about it that makes it so
challenging well it has to be perfectly
positioned and we can't bump into
anything it's very heavy and slow and
you don't want it to swing like a
pendulum okay another four millimeters
when it's done the concrete structure
will be clad with more than 20,000
square metres of sand stone and brick
the palace is scheduled for completion
in 2018 right now they're working on a
side entry way back in Dresden Schubert
staff can follow the progress live via
web cam they use a computer to map out
the original design then they use the
computer to devise a 3d copy of the
original stonework the parameters are
transmitted to a robot
the robot has been working on this piece
three days non-stop it would have taken
a stonemason two weeks to make this
before ending that's a sign defense some
Amendola being the best moment is when
it's finally done but getting there
involves a lot of brutally hard work I
wanna 30 now we've got our one-armed
bandit here who helps out they have
several projects for the palace going
simultaneously the robot did the rough
carving for this Angels wing but the
creative detail work has to be done by
hand sculptor Ralph Connie will spend a
week on the final carving he makes sure
that his recreated version matches the
original lozenge me with an earth-sized
skips labelled up for them to take the
measurements from a one-to-one plaster
model with a compass copula Pakistan and
transfer it to stone here with my pencil
and stand on my before begin with my
staff union he stood behind
a raw slab like this one costs about a
thousand euros
the slab gets divided up into big blocks
for the stonemasons slide look we can
also cut slices off the slabs using
something much like a boiled egg cutter
easily get turned into columns for
Berlin soy or your belly eaten the
columns for the big entryway are just
being completed Schubert's company has
been working on the baroque portal for
two years already it will adorn the
berlin city palace when it opens in 2018
for Schubert one thing is clear a
project like this comes once in a
lifetime
you